come on in pal i can look now peek-a-boo
[Music]
you know our next guest from the hit
show tanked where they built
over-the-top aquariums well now brett
raimer is building over-the-top
sandwiches at his new restaurant
stallone's italian eatery he joins us
now with chef louie great to see you
guys hey what's up buddy good to see you
bro okay tell me what about the
restaurant what's the theme of the
restaurant so you know i love food and
i've always loved food and i'm from new
york and i've been in vegas 28 years and
i can never really find the you know
that right new york italian food and
then i met chef louis who we
accidentally we grew up together in the
same neighborhood but didn't know each
other we accidentally met here in vegas
and uh i tasted this food and i was like
this is what i'm talking about new york
food so i was like man we got to open up
a place and that's pretty much how we
got started it has opened up within the
past couple of months it's brand new the
place has taken off you have pizzas what
kind of pizzas do you guys offer us so
today we have uh this pizza's named
after chef louie this is his arugula
and then over here we have uh it's an
old school with pepperoni we're gonna
make uh what's what's the most popular
item on the menu right now um i would
have to say the godfather sandwich and
uh chef louie's meatballs okay chef
louise meatballs in the godfather
sandwich we're gonna make the godfather
what goes into the godfather what do we
need first we've got um chef lewis right
here he makes himself at home already
absolutely he is back here he's already
in the kitchen toast and bread yeah he's
taking over things and then also you
have a really cool to-go set up how does
that work yeah so our art to go system
is a lot different than a lot of places
you go around town and you uh have to
wait when you order your food yeah with
us we take your phone number over the
phone or online and then we actually
text you when it's ready so if you live
within you know a five mile radius you
don't have to wait around you get a text
and you can come as it's coming out of
the oven and you'll see brett's in the
restaurant too he's hanging out he's
making food he's doing things okay how
do we what's the first step here chef uh
our homemade chicken cutlets is this
mine is the one i make no no we're gonna
get a hold on oh okay
okay continue though okay i got uh
homemade homemade uh bread crumbs that
we've we made homemade bread comes
perfect this is prosciutto de palma
where's the restaurant located so it's
uh it's in the silverado ranch area it's
uh 467 east silverado ranch boulevard
suite number 125.
how did how did you come up with this
concept it was all that prosciutto jason
sure i'm not i'm not that poor
we don't we don't we don't chance out at
stallone no i've seen i've seen the
finished product it's over the top with
some cheese some cheese two pieces on
each side so one of the things about our
sandwiches i think you need to add some
more cheese more cheese one of the
things about our sandwiches is we call
them heroes we don't call them subs so
our slogan is why be a sub when you
could be a hero
and uh we're launching a new program
next month it's going to be called
heroes for heroes so when you buy one of
our sandwiches next month there's going
to be a little card inside of it that's
going to actually have a community hero
and then you'll be able to donate to
that community person's charity so we'll
tell you a little bit about the person
and what they're doing for our community
and then we kind of help promote it
through our sandwiches so you guys are
you guys are giving back to las vegas
absolutely you know i do have to ask you
i mean you tanked was a hit show for
eight plus years animal planet we miss
you guys is the show going to come back
and as much as i'd probably like it to
come back i would i don't know it was a
lot of work i mean you know making
television how hard it is
it took up a lot of my time and i'll be
honest with you i'm really into the food
right now i want to i think i want to
take this place right here and i want to
take this
you got it and i want to take it to new
levels oh my gosh the sandwich is
colossal you've gone from building those
like you should say on the show tank if
you dream it we can build it yeah if you
can dream the sandwich you guys can
build it at stones is that right
absolutely chef louis is amazing at his
recipes and the things that he creates
and this is like i said one of our most
famous sandwiches right here the
godfather oh man brett thank you so much
for joining us chef louis thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate it
pleasure stallone's italian eatery you
got to go check out brett and check out
these sandwiches i'm going to try this i
got to read something so all right